don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
hey babe hey babe what's going on
i
well first of all what's going on is i
just say dill
spicy chip uh pickled flavored potato
chips delicious
i mean
might have been the best bag of chips
i've ever had just made it with the
expiration date by the way which i know
you think is bs spunk but i wouldn't be
able to eat it if it's said any later
than that but it literally on a potato
chip you can't eat past the expiration
date i can i won't
you can't you won't what do you feel is
happening in a chip i just tons of
sodium i'm sure it's preserved good
enough
i just think that i'm gonna get a
stomach ache which i'm probably going to
get anyway because i shouldn't be eating
spicy foods i got three whole potatoes
in the mail yesterday i didn't i swear
to god they downstairs i should grab
them i didn't know what i was getting
them for i should have got them why do
you have three whole potatoes i opened
it up and it said it literally said the
scoopski potato tour which is the name
of the tour i'm doing with the guys okay
that is on sale right now go to the
tenderloins.com tour for tickets coming
to a city near you uh
it just i opened up and it said the
scoops potato tour is coming to a city
near you on sale now and the back
literally in actual typed ink
like printed ink on the potato it said
go to the tenderloins.com tour for
tickets i got a bunch of them in the
mail
i don't know who's ended or why
i it's my tour like what what do they
think you're going to do like do they
want you to go outside and start handing
out the potatoes i could just cut out
gravel take one minute
i mean you got it's good promo for the
tour anyway yeah
it's right around you named the whole
tour after that one potato bit yeah
yeah
i get this in the mail
and i it's true it says there's three of
these three these gold boxes in there
okay says you'll never guess what's
inside okay okay see that
it doesn't yeah no by the way no heads
up
i don't know who they're from i don't
know who this is from right i opened it
up yesterday i'm like here we
go inside our potatoes
what i didn't see that you got your face
on this one oh my face is on that i
didn't see that face on this one you got
both of them you got you oh and this is
mers faces on the other one look this is
the one i opened yesterday
it just says the impractical jokers
scoopski potato tour
get your tickets now
at the tenderloins.com
i got five potatoes delivered to a box
in my home they're real potatoes it's
from potato parcel
that's a sticker can i take the sticker
from my stepson please
[Laughter]
the instagram is i got a potato yeah one
potato two potatoes wow
imagine you're the only one from the
jokers that got this they didn't send it
to anybody else i don't think i got them
from this company i think this company
is the one who makes this but i don't
know who sent me this but
nonetheless get your tickets now
scoops you potato tour did i tell you
what do you know what that's a reference
to no
we're we did a bid at a restaurant like
a long time ago uh red's restaurant over
by giant stadium actually okay it's like
a like an old uh family-run restaurant
sounds good
yeah red's it's good right so uh we we
had to do this thing where
uh the restaurant was packed right and
then we just had to approach a table
with a big [ __ ] a big freaking bowl of
mashed potatoes
and just
present ourselves as if we worked there
but without saying anything go to people
to eating and add mashed potatoes to
their plate yeah and the more that you
could add without them stopping you
would dictate who would win who would
win and so joe when he went he just was
like i'm gonna just bowl them over
i think he was the last person of the
day because we have to be careful not to
like blow up the room right because if
they see something's going on you know
then we have to wait till the whole
thing turns over right so we still do it
discreetly then he came out and he was
just like i'm going last and he just was
like he just would walk up the tail and
be like you want a scoop say i got
potatoes you want a scoop i've got
potatoes and he just took the squish and
he just started whipping
potatoes at people there was it was like
shrapnel potatoes going everywhere they
were loving it
he did one over he did one blind over
the back of his shoulder that was insane
what year was that
uh
maybe season three-ish oh a long time
ago then yeah yeah a long time ago i'll
tell you
i actually did i tell you that story
about how i went to bruno mars concert
invited from him i met him somewhere he
invited us to his concert and so i drove
up to albany to see him in concert with
capitol new york that's right
and um coolest dude ever it was like
really nice went backstage hanging out
he was making drinks right we were
having some drinks guys right he's he is
shorter he was shorter than me yeah and
i'm not that's all so yeah yeah but uh
just really really cool dude and making
drinks laughing talking whatever uh and
then
we get we go and we we go underneath the
stage because he shows us my buddy sean
what's up sean shout out sean sean did
you spell it a-s-e-a-n or s-h-a-u-n
s-h-a-u-n
i don't i don't love him as much as i
did before sean hoffman he's a brutal
core manager shout out shawn hoffman uh
buddy of mine any and he took us
underneath the stage and showed us like
in the middle of there's like a dressing
room under the stage for anything quick
that bruno needs and it's like it's set
up down there it's got the mirror with
the lights he's changing clothes his gum
minced tea
tissues towels you know a couch and like
in between he runs down i guess where
there's something you know so we we're
down there and we're it's before the the
definitely funny in between sets he
needs a quick tea
you never know
gray i know sometimes you do need an
earl grey yeah and uh
so we wrote on on a piece of paper right
down there bruno it was me and joey down
there like bruno shows decent so far
because he goes he gets there at midway
point of the show so he wasn't gonna see
it until midway in the show yeah so he
wrote a note with a black market so it
shows decent so far but you need to step
it up a bit yeah and we started on names
and we left it and uh i'm told sean told
me that
he either laminated it or kept it in
good condition and kept it on that
mirror for the rest of the tour wow to
give him a little motivation at the
halfway point that's hilarious but while
we're in the stands and he's doing his
finale it's like the encore and there's
literally
fireworks going off like pyrotechnics
right and he's on like one of his famous
songs it's an encore and he screams out
scoops get potatoes
wow in the crowd as a reference to the
show you guys were there for that
okay so we were all there right i'm in
the states and i'm recording him on my
phone
and i don't realize he said it and the
crowd goes nuts and i turn to the guys
and the guy's going oh my god that's so
cool
and i was like yeah it's so cool he's
he's great it's the fireworks and
they're like no no what do you mean you
just screamed quote
potatoes because he just screamed quotes
from the show and i was like i didn't
hear him wow
because you were on your phone i was on
my phone but listen but you have the
video
to to you have the video so you can
re-watch it and play play it um that is
yeah that's that's an awesome people
know is why we named it that was my
point that was one of the best bits
of the jokers i love the potato tour i
love that the potato thing yeah that was
just like
joey i remember on the sides and joe was
like ah man i'm the last one it's late i
got because i'm just gonna do it like
insane yeah i'm just gonna start running
around just whipping mashed potatoes at
people and see what they do and i'm like
do it do it yeah has there ever been a
bit that's cut from the show it's just
bombed yeah
because it because it bonds uh we
haven't had one in a long while we kind
of got more efficient at making them and
know how to do it but like in the
beginning we had some real big misses we
did one i don't know who thought this
was a good idea we played mimes in
central park so we weren't allowed to
speak
it was it was dude it was a no joke was
an easily a 98 degree day and we're in
the makeup the makeup is pouring off our
faces getting into our eyes
like like toxic makeup all of our eyes
are bloodshot red and we're out there
and we're going and we can't talk the
bit was that we were mimed so like it's
just bombing we're sweating the
paint is half off no one's giving us the
time of day we can't really speak
we finished with it we're like that was
the worst thing we've ever done in our
entire life so you just completely
caught it no one's ever seen it ever i
would love to see it it's so bad and
then another time we went to a kids park
right and this was the this was
this was the idea we had we didn't
realize it would be problematic we went
to a children's playground and the idea
was to baby talk to adults
okay okay like whoever could do it the
most like and oh no the you could do it
until like if you can get the person to
just
somehow stop baby talking back to you
without asking them okay so the idea
we're like well where would you shoot
that because if you just walk to a
person in the street and go excuse me do
you know where there's somebody yeah
that they'll look you like you're crazy
so what if we went to a children's park
and then like if there's kids and babies
around we could be in the park and we
could talk to the kids that way first
and then if they're with the parent we
could turn to the parent and then say
our thought but still say it in the kid
way that might be a nice organic place
that we can actually assuage the person
to
talk back to us and not take care crazy
little did we know we showed up to our
children's park as just middle-aged men
with no kids and we were like just
walking around and looking at all the
kids and talking to all the kids
and like we were like hey baby and then
i'm just alone yeah
so then we're like okay go run and get
like um
a prop stroller that's empty and they'll
just think one of our kids is running
around but no one bought it and the
parents were freaked by us and they
called the cops and the cops came really
yeah and they were like yeah we got a
report that you guys are just weird
older guys walking around the park just
trying to talk to every child that's
hull and that's another one i want to
see patreon.com
completely cut
whose idea was that i don't remember
okay you guys don't give each other [ __ ]
we do i it's just that so many ideas
come
building on other ideas and from so many
different people contributing that like
i i'll remember if one was my idea i but
i don't remember like i don't remember
what's up everybody tomorrow i'm gonna
be in fort lauderdale at the dania
improv with tt jerry we got friday we
got saturday we're gonna go wild next
weekend september 24th to the 26th
irvine improv october 1st with sally
babe co-headlining the lyric in
baltimore october 2nd we added a show in
pittsburgh pennsylvania october
23rd we added a show at foxwoods go get
it and october 29th big one durham north
carolina also co-headlining with the
babes avocado and november 21st the
wilbur theater in boston
chrisdcomedy.com for tickets thank you i
love you babe all right cute kids come
see me in austin september 24th at the
paramount theater that's for the moon
tower comedy festival uh i will be
headlining there and then the next day
september 25th i will be in denver at
the bellco theater with david spade and
frank caliendo for charity uh all ticket
to salvocanocomedy.com and then i'm on
tour with the guys this tour has started
it's an arena tour i'll tell you the
first weekend uh glendale arizona san
diego california and sacramento
california those are the first big dates
but all dates are up and they're at the
tenderloins.com
tour but this is interesting yeah i i
it's it's i think a lot of people don't
understand like you know
like i i read something oh i listened to
uh billy on the street billy eichner
because i start die laughing at his show
as well he was saying like
literally in that half an hour show he
has probably 10 hours of footage for
every show of things that just bomb
people that just don't give him what he
wants he was like i think he kind of
said what you said as the show went on
he got better and better at it but at
least in the beginning it was literally
10 12 hour days to maybe get one or two
bits that would make the show yeah just
get those gold bits yeah cause you look
at those bits the bits that do make air
sometimes they're like how the heck did
he get that lucky yeah it's a numbers
game it's a numbers game yeah yeah 10
hours for 22 minutes you ever met him
billy eichner yeah yeah he was on true
for a while yeah i had met him like
peripherally on twitter first because
before he was on true
he was still running around in the same
locations as us filming the show really
so we were these two men on the street
new york shows that were filming at the
same time and hitting it kind of the
same so sometimes you would be doing a
joker's bit right next to him doing a
building once or twice that's sick is it
ever like make it in the background of
each other's shots no but that would be
one time in washington square park we
realized he was there and i and i
tweeted him and we saw him and we were
there too and he was running around with
it because he just runs around with one
camera guy right pretty much i guess i
think so yeah yeah maybe two but uh yeah
i know that's yeah that's awesome yeah
yeah and then he was on true and so we
had to do upfront and stuff together and
everything now is is new york ever an
issue for your shooting like has the
city ever interrupted a day of shooting
there are times where you can get your
permits like for your permit um
like revoked
if you do something or you or something
happens they they will like it's very
much like uh
tick-tock jail
which i'm in right now
my tick tock is in freaking jail right
check us out on all the socials volcano
christy comedy go to our tick tocks go
to the top no no uh yeah but there were
like there are times where like a
location are like you never come back
here again and it's like costco never
like overwhelming jokers they're like we
don't
ikea ever let us back again that was the
beginning when no one even knew who we
were as we were like we couldn't believe
we got these locations right but then
like one thing could go like
if one person complains or something
like that they might think better now
it's like hey we go there it's like you
know you're getting a commercial like
costco is going to be on an eight-minute
bit straight you know what i mean right
so a lot of times people will just do it
just for that but then sometimes they're
you know they might be adverse to it or
do you brush your teeth in the shower
no or in the sink in the sink really
yeah do you in the shower yeah
is that bad every day
yeah that's where you brush them i got
my toothbrush in the
heard that shower not crazy it's not
crazy but it's not normal i don't know i
mean i i do a little routine
i have um a water pick that i like to
use sometimes i also do the mouth rinse
afterwards okay
where do you put your deodorant on in
the bathroom or in you know like in your
room or or you know part of my bathroom
routine babe i got a whole routine right
what's your routine all right i get in
there okay i turn on the water first
first to get it going okay i make sure i
turn on the fan i put the lights at a
level that i like sometimes i like it
bright i want to wake up sometimes i
like it low if i want a little bit of a
moody shower sure you understand if
you're about to manage the bait in the
shower one of those whatever yeah i get
a towel i put a towel on the floor and i
put a towel right by the edge so when i
get out i'm not freezing wow all right
planning ahead yeah lots a lot of times
i'll set up a little my little things on
on the sink
and i get in i go through the whole
routine i do hair i do conditioner i do
the body i do a face scrub i do when you
do the body do you do do you just do
armpits genitalia and butt or do you do
everything i do everything i am not like
mila kunis and ashton kutcher got it
that's what i was gonna ask okay uh what
else do i do um do you wash underneath
your feet in between your toes yes i do
i've never i can't well i can't remember
ever washing my feet
well i i don't make i don't make a huge
like parade out of it i just go down and
i do it you know yeah good flexibility
then
you can't you can yeah you got to reach
your feet no i ca i can but it's just
like i have a little one of those seats
that i could sit on
to hit it
okay yeah so that's what you do and then
and then you come out what am i doing i
also do a beard a beard treatment
what do you do for the beard i'd put a
little bit of like special uh
like
oils and stuff in it okay in the shower
yeah i have like a like a like a beard
uh balm thing right okay then i wa wash
be it wash and then you come out do you
immediately put the owner in i have a
hole to do when i come out what's the
first i towel bone dry in the shower
because it's too cold out there wow so
you bring this the towel and i open it
up i bring the towel in i i get fully
dry in the shower wow then before i even
exit the shower i get this squeegee
and i hit all four walls
no i swear to christ yeah because that's
gonna get hard water build up and and
it's gonna it's gonna look bad after a
couple of weeks
oh my god yeah so i cleaned that whole
shower down what are you doing very
methodically you don't care in a hotel
like a hotel i've watered down no i spit
on have water damage yeah i can't have
that no they have someone come in so i
do that whole thing now i step out of
the shower i lay the towel down i step
onto the towel
baby powder
everywhere i just yeah i look like
frosty the snowman
[Laughter]
boxers leave the shirt off because i'm
gonna brush i don't want anything on the
shirt okay do the brushing
flossing
rinse
do a little eye cream
which i started using only in the last
couple years because i've learned that
self-care and skin care is very
important i've only realized this
recently
what do you mean eye cream like
different products yeah for circles for
lines i just put a little on nice
usually right before bed
so it absorbs i want to hydrate this
area your area yeah then i'll do um just
a little bit of if it's overnight i'll
do it oil in the beard if it's daytime
i'll do a bomb because the oil makes a
little too soft okay
i'll slick my hair back nice i'll just
put a light holding product in it so
it's not all over the place when i go to
bed
hit up the deodorant then put on the
shirt
at that point
i might touch up my beard just a little
bit
and then i think i'm good
wow sometimes if i really feel dry i'll
moisturize my whole face with a separate
product let me ask you this please you
put deodorant on if you're not going out
always
what right before bed always any time
you wear deodorant before bed if you're
not going out i probably have too much
uh
too much uh
[ __ ] no like aluminum yeah like that
kind of [ __ ] in me because i put it on
like nobody's business because oh and
that clogs your pores yeah increases
they say but the only way to combat that
is you got any blueberries those are
antioxidants that's right it's the only
way you got to combat the oxidants with
blueberries yeah i can't believe that
you put deodorant on
if you're not going out i do oh q-tip i
do a q-tip and you comb your hair no
matter what always
wow i don't walk out of the shower
without my head only because
well maybe in the past when it was
shorter but now it's like i can't really
not tend to it
your hair you think this this this look
is here to stay the people want to know
not even close one when are you going to
make a decision i already cut it like
and it keeps going
i don't even know i'm bored with
everything could you shave your head at
this point in your life i've done it no
i'm talking about like you know
could you i think i would do it if i
lost a few lbs first right it's nice
it's freeing it is free i like just
going right out not even worrying about
it getting up waking up not even
worrying about it so i'm out of here it
was very freeing you've had that too
i've seen i've shaved my head multiple
times you don't have a routine out of
the bathroom my so i get in the shower i
wipe everything down also i got a whole
thing i get in the shower i turn the
shower on i turn the shower on usually
here's what i do use a toner
nothing use a toner i use a i use one of
those like male you know 18 in one
shampoo conditioner hair wash one thing
everything
yeah you know
lotion
they really do try to get it yeah
everything it's everything it is all
those things it's soap toothbrush and
mayo
literally it's like you you don't have
to do anything like if you have that
take eleven and one you can be a mission
you can it becomes a shake weight yeah
so yeah so i i do that i wash my hair
no matt i told you i said this foreign
podcast if i take four showers a day i
wash my hair every time so what i and i
literally stripping it over those
natural oils though babe i should talk
to them i know i know i should i should
i should be more conscious of my oils
what what goes on your body soap wise
are you putting on just are you
slathering up your hands are you putting
the bar so straight to your body do you
have a washcloth are you using a loofah
are you using one of those sponge and
spongy things i'd always prefer a loofah
i'd always prefer a loofah if i but
usually i go with a washcloth a couple
of days ago i didn't have a washcloth or
a loofah and i cannot wash my body with
my hands because i only use liquid soap
i do not like bars of soap okay i only
use a liquid soap and i did not have a
washcloth or a loop already which one
body washed i washed myself with a scrub
daddy
i put some no
that's probably a great exfoliant it
felt great because it got real soft and
i washed myself down with the scrub
daddy with my um uh i think i was using
um why did you have a scrub daddy in the
shower though
i guess
kids jasmine must clean the walls with
their scrubs oh that's very not good
though so your scrub daddy was full of
probably ammonia and soap scum because
if that's what you're scrubbing the
tiles with you don't want to scrub that
daddy all over your own i don't want to
tell you you're bringing it up now yeah
i'm not even lying i've had a pretty
much constant itch
for the past three days oh you got all
sorts because i never told my family
that i used the scrub daddy i just used
it oh yeah you're not supposed to use
that that's probably a clorox without a
doubt without a doubt you probably
bleached your [ __ ] and didn't even
know it
wow
scrub daddy i think that is the most
successful selling product on um shark
tank of all time is it really we might
have talked about that before yeah you
have yeah scrub daddy most successful uh
product call her daddy very successful
podcast
call her daddy call her daddy 60 million
spotify deal wow spotify deal i have
i'm not familiar with it but
who i'm you know i mean 60 million yeah
yeah if you got the name daddy in the
name daddy is
there's a lot i want a bot i want to be
associated i want to buy something named
daddy
i like daddy in a name i don't know what
you mean
like i guess you want to buy
you feel
a pretty is it what's the word i'm
looking for
pr
predilection explicitly uh what was the
word we use um lasticity elasticity you
feel elasticity that you you have an
urge
to buy
things that are branded with the name
daddy in it for example the scrub daddy
it's just the best name if it was called
the scrub father or the scrub mommy i
probably wouldn't use it yeah call her
daddy good name for a podcast i'm
listening
call her mommy call her father i'm not
listening
yeah what is that thing with the call
her
with the dad i think daddy dearest is
more famous than mommy dearest
oh i don't know about that mommy dearest
because in the movie
what do you mean daddy dearest do you
think mommy mommy dearest things more
there was a movie called mommy dearest
who's in it um is it fake
not any bots
she plays an abusive mom she beats her
daughter with the wire hangers now show
me faye dunaway because i've heard the
name a thousand times i couldn't i don't
know what faye done oh you know faye
dunaway's face but i wanna see her there
it is faye dunaway that's nice that's
faye dunaway yeah but that's her now you
also want to see her back then but you
get who she is right oh no no i've seen
faye dunaway oh my god it's so funny
when you write when you type in faye
dunaway on google after faye dunaway you
know how it usually pre-populates like
husband net worth like you know whatever
kids faye dunaway populates every year
of when you put the one in it's
1980 70 67 85 68 81 90 because i guess
people want to see her at all at
different ages i think let's pick our
best fei done away i like i like 1970
faye dunaway yeah now why is she famous
faye dunaway she's she's a very famous
actress is she alive
i'm going to guess faye dunaway is alive
i'm going to guess she's alive and
against her birthday's october 21st
uh
1923 i'm going to guess her death will
be
september 15th 2026.
uh yes 194.
she was born right in the beginning of
world war one she actually caused world
war one she's eight her birth cause
she's 80 right now let's do the let's do
a thing love you fate donald is there is
there a uh a website dedicated to
guessing if people are dead or alive
let's see yeah let's play the game dead
or alive are they dead are they alive
what celebrities are dead or a lot
ninety-seven percent of people can't
figure out if these celebrities are dead
or alive here we go
okay
carrie fisher dead
dead boom
robin williams unfortunately dead
unfortunately that well carrie fisher
unfortunately okay all these people are
unfortunately dead unfortunately
whoever's dead charlie sheen
unfortunately alive
no i'm kidding shout out charlie i love
you i sent you a dm to be on my christy
chaos podcast you read it thankfully
never got back to me so suck it yeah if
you're watching and we know that y'all
know you are heath ledger dead dead yeah
these are 97 percent of people don't
know if these two
tupac debatable
yeah debatable yeah dead yeah but how
does anybody get this wrong janet
jackson's alive
don't waste our time george michael dead
oh is he yeah that was tragic
justin bieber
bill paxton dead dead or is he alive he
did die sorry bill man come on michael
clark duncan is dead oh god he was great
river phoenix is dead so we're scoring
97 of people can't get this right and
we're scoring a hundred they're like
michael jackson
dead
come on
kirk douglas recently dead i think
recently dead no he's not
no but there's but he just he died after
this quiz came out he's dead now wow
bernie mac is dead
celine dion is alive
let me ask you how does bernie mac die
from like the flu of pneumonia can he
yes crazy at soccer psychiatrists some
inflammation of his um
lungs it's like it's like a genetic
disorder i mean this is getting
ridiculous angela actually angela
lansbury alive she's alive this is the
first step come on angie angie lansey
live
mary tyler is dead dead
jerry lewis he died recently didn't he
oh he's alive sorry jerry but i i i i
don't
i don't know if he is though i know i
think that this when did this quiz come
aliyah's dead oh sorry leah now they're
asking
kurt cobain
and uh she died a couple years later you
killed her no
now when you guys get to this point of
your career how would you take being on
this quiz
i think these people are really really
famous though
what's florence henderson known from she
from florence in the machine
no she's um an actress oh she was in um
wasn't she in like
hogan the hogan family am i crazy
she was a spokesperson for like uh the
brady bunch i think like crisco or
something like that
of course the brady but i thought you
meant outside the brady bunch i didn't
even know she was from the brady she's
the mom oh okay
okay
yeah good show the brady bunch huh
never seen a single episode of it really
is it fantastic
um i grew up on it right you know i mean
it's
it's
now it's probably be good to watch just
for like kitschy purposes it's not like
he's gonna be like you're gonna be into
it but yeah
okay all right so that was a terrible
quiz though that was a terrible quiz um
would that bit have made the impractical
jokers or would you edit that one out
that bit that would have been chicken
what is that where'd you get this from
so this is who's who's more sexual as a
as a as a
as a country or
ethnicity okay the most sexual ethnicity
i could see it being brazil the number
of sexual encounters per year by a
person
in that country brazil 145
russia 143 tied with poland wow
i cause i think of when i think of sex i
think of brazil i don't think of poland
no zilch not saying polish people aren't
sex i think they're sexy as [ __ ]
there's something this i feel like
there's a bit of an all or nothing out
there in the
in the european countries yeah like it's
supermodel or
likes
like i think like i don't know the way
that dna goes out out there is it just
it's not distributed it's not
distributed it's like wealth here yes
you know what i mean yeah it's a
sexuality it's like there's a there's a
there's a one piece there's a one
percent there's no middle middle
you're either a smoke show you are an
absolute smoke show or i can't even
believe you're barely human yeah with
your luck
[Laughter]
but don't you feel that like i i it's
never a moderately pleasant european
person they're either like they're lit
they're
on billboards all across the world or
you know yeah they they look a certain
way that wouldn't be on a billboard
right right is that a way to say that
that is a way to say it yeah but check i
guess we have that here too of course i
mean of course right yeah yeah but i
think i see a lot more average people in
the states yes when i'm over there it's
like oh that person has to see the
marley area here yeah yeah whoa that
person definitely sells
they use that person to sell diamonds
yeah they sell they sell yes
butcher box babe babe i got nine to 11
pounds of meat beef poultry and fish on
me at all times because a bunch of boxes
oh because they're butcher boxes i was
looking i said what the hell but i was
like nine to 11 pounds
never forget at all
i mean butcher box it's a no-brainer
yeah i mean there's meat everywhere it's
packed fresh shipped frozen and vacuum
sealed so they take actually take a
vacuum cleaner and seal it i mean they
have everything though okay and it's top
of the line stuff it's a hundred percent
grass-fed beef it's wild caught lobster
tails it's free-range chicken uh
humanely raised pork wild-caught alaskan
salmon you get the picture nitrate free
free bacon how do they make nitrate free
breaking i don't know how they do it but
they don't do it i'm not here to
question how they do it i'm here to
receive the beef and consume the beef
that's what i want i want the butcher to
hit my box that's right
if you listen let me ask you a question
at home yeah do you enjoy great tasting
high quality meat deliver right to your
door do you or don't you answer me
everybody does okay so then we have an
offer for you and it's free shipping and
it's free shipping here we go you ready
for this
all you got to do is go to
butcherbox.com
slash hey babe for free chicken
burgers and hot dogs in your first box
getting free food
is that is that what's happening that's
what's happening box wants you to enjoy
the rest of summer with a special deal
they're giving our listeners this offer
three pounds of chicken breasts two
pounds of burgers a package of hot dogs
for free right now new members can get
the special deal when they sign up at
butcherbox.com hey babe free chicken
burgers hot dogs in your first box you
can't
lose i poached a lobster tail the other
day was so delicious from butcher box
punched my grandmother in the mouth
afterwards all right i didn't even feel
guilt all right peter
babe this is one that we've been talking
about you take the multivitamin i take
the multivitamin it's awesome this
multivitamin it's it's got no sugar no
gmos no major allergens no synthetic
fillers and no artificial colorants so
that's why i love it it's a good multi-v
because here's the thing multivitamins
pretty much do the same thing but this
one's got the key nutrients your body
can actually help
that your boxy body actually needs to
help fill in the gaps in your diet so
vitamin d3 in just two daily pills
everybody needs a little bit of vitamin
d i want to say this one because i like
it so much i always say that they're
traceable yeah which i think is kind of
cool i just feel like i i don't know i
like knowledge knowledge is power
and you'll always know where your
nutrients have come from with ritual
well because they uh they have a
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain the
other day i asked my six-year-old
daughter i said you know while she was
getting really like you know just we
didn't have anything to do for her she
was bored i said why don't you trace
something you know she traced the ritual
vitamins through your body
that's what she traced i like to know
what i'm putting in my body no joke yes
that's why i do enjoy using rituals and
here you're gonna get a nice discount go
to ritual.com hey babe 10 off your first
three months ritual.com hey babe 10 off
your first three months start your
ritual today
who what country has the ugliest people
irish men and german women are the
ugliest in the world so there you go
irish men and women
who's like a rockin hot irish guy
i can't think of one
carol i don't know colin farrell is a
good one yeah he's a rock and hot irish
consider generally a sex symbol correct
yes uh is mcgregor
yes i
yes
who's a rock and hot irish woman gal
lass
sinead o'connor
yeah
yeah not great well i mean
when she was younger um she definitely
captured a look
i think now i've seen her recently and
she's an older woman now so i wouldn't
describe her currently for me
right as rock and hot nor would i
describe myself as such look at this
girl stella maxwell is she irish
oh boy all right well there you go oh
there's one well there's one
georgina what's this one's name
georgina
salpa
yeah if you guys could choose would you
rather be george prettiest version of
who you could be or the ugliest
i mean prettiest prettiest you want to
be pretty i like a natural beauty
in anyone me too i don't like work i'm
never going to get my tits done never it
won't happen i guarantee you that as
long as we do this podcast mine are
going to stay nice and big and firm what
if what if one of the what if one of the
punishments for the biggest loser of
let's say if you guys do another
impractical joker's movie is whoever
loses has to get breast augmentation
surgery would you do it
we almost did that shut up yeah we
almost did it for the i think it was for
the movie or something what do you mean
someone was going to get i think murrah
was going to get president
yeah stop like for real yeah we have to
figure out if they can be taken back out
and reversed and things like that yeah i
i'm near positive we go through a lot of
ideas but i think murray pressed
implanted yeah insane yeah yeah
what would you do i have to tell you
about i got uh yeah i told you this you
could you could have killed him
you can kanye's mom died in breast
surgery no i didn't know the exact
details of it but it wasn't yes i think
she was getting a routine breast
augmentation whoa you're cutting hope
you were just gonna cut open merged
chest yeah wow true tv pushes it to the
limit i i don't know if they approved it
backyard bar wars thursday's 10 30.
we're pushing it to the limit episode 10
coming out i get fake tits
in the up i do what the jokers couldn't
i i i got breast i told this story i
think on this podcast but
i got breast glued to me four and a half
pounds each like you know this is
brilliant never told us this for a from
a mo for a pilot that we did where the
doctor mixes up i false my my storyline
was that i fall asleep in the weight in
in a in a room i was visiting queue
who's in there for smoke inhalation
because he's a fireman this is the so we
did a pilot and uh i fall asleep in the
bed next to him he leaves to go find
this little kid who
another storyline and the doctor comes
in and i'm laying in a bed that has a
chart on it that says i'm getting breast
augmentation and i'm sleeping so they
wheel me out and i wake up in recovery
with with huge hits
and and i actually we actually got like
the um the things that women use to fill
like but they use it in movies but they
also probably use it like if they have
you know
like you know i don't think they have
breast cancer whatever but these like
realistic things or if they just have
small breasts part of the itty bitty
titty yeah the committee yeah and uh i i
gotta tell you i think i told you this
no because also the weird thing was that
they they were black breasts
no you never told us that you once had
fake pictures fake black like triple d
breasts they were four and a half pounds
each i put nine pounds on my head and
this is before black lives matter this
is before at all wow and uh and my back
was i mean in shambles after a day of
filming
nine pounds just like all day long and i
had a huge bra on but i i think i told
you this no no there's no way you did in
the sketch i get i realized i'm walking
down the hall and i see it in the mirror
and i i'm like oh my god so i go up to
the nurse's station i furious and i
ripped my shirt open and they just hang
in there
and i and there's a black nurse and she
looks at me and she goes name
and i go name
i'm like look at me i am black brass
what you doing here she goes calm down
sorry go calm down i go how would you
like it if you had a white dick
and she goes she goes that depends
but this is a real person no it was she
was an actress it was almost
yeah yeah yeah
what for what network was it a pilot for
it was independent pilot that we did and
it didn't go it was really funny though
why don't we try to get it back we got
into the new york television festival as
a pilot and then i took we took a few
meetings off of it but we had a pilot
for spike that was a single camera that
didn't get picked up but the experience
wasn't good we would have changed a lot
of stuff but it was we were working with
another production company that we
didn't think did it justice and it was
like watered down and it was weird and
everything so when we were done with
that experience and we had like a hunt
like a hundred grand to do that and it
was like they passed and then we were
like we could do this better ourselves
and then we just called in favors and
made another pilot single cam dude
speaking of that you know you know who
must have just made 100 grand
must have
for winning the super bowl
tom brady probably easily
bonuses i know they give him a car and
so congratulations by the way congrats
to you man and also in the tampa bay box
they won in their homes in tampa yes
first time yeah so what happened and
then pastor was written from holmes is
by the way great player from the kansas
city chiefs they lost yeah what can you
do yeah but they won already and they're
going to win again yes i mean so
congrats to patrick holmes congrats to
tom brady um shout out to all athletes
shout out to all championship level
sports shout out the road to getting the
championship level yes and shout out the
hundred thousand dollars you probably
want to that's a big sum that's right
shout out legal tender shout out legal
tender illegal tender launch legal
tenderloins yeah yeah i um
i uh
so the story about those breasts were
and
man i think i told this story i swear
there is not a shot in hell you told the
story okay it'll be really funny if i
did i can't wait for all the comments
you definitely i went to this woman's
house and we had to get a special
effects makeup woman to put the breasts
on me for this because we had other
effects too and uh like mental health
effects no like special effects okay
like you know we like there's a whole
bunch of stuff like murray murray's
trying to hit on a nurse that he likes
and he wants to impress her so he throws
a magic show for the children's award
and he and he asks her a volunteer and
he puts her on the spinning wheel and
throws knives but they all pierce her
so like when she stops spinning she has
like 11 knives in her and the kids are
just screaming and everything
this is an awesome
sketch show thank you very yeah so uh no
it's a narrative show right it's a
single camera yeah yeah yeah yeah look
at this look at my tommy john underwear
they come out under my shorts yeah now
yeah all right i'm just covering my legs
you're all over the place
you gotta you're one shade darker than
last week though well thank you i've
been tanning my legs only yeah only
likes
so we get this lady and she speaks
broken english and i forget her name uh
and she goes come to my apartment
i'm not going to speak broken your
shoulder she has come to my apartment
she says um and i will uh pre uh she
wanted to you know try out the breasts
different sizes how they would stick the
glues so i said all right so i go to her
house it's in like brooklyn or something
it's a
scorching hot summer day right and and i
go there it's like one of those dog days
of summer and i get there she doesn't
have air conditioning she opens the door
she has a tiny apartment she lives with
her husband he's home all their windows
are open it's like a hundred degrees
nast they're in the middle of eating
dinner oh so i'm like hey so she goes oh
hey come in come and come in so she goes
come to the couch lay down so she goes
just lay down so first she goes take
your shirt off so her husband's there
eating dinner the food's on the table so
she's shaving my chest because she has
to glue the breast to my chest so she's
shaving my chest in front of her husband
while he's eating dinner then she gets
it all shaved i don't have a lot of hair
so she gets a little shaved she wipes me
down she says all right now i'm going to
glue these breasts to you we're going to
try different sizes i'll start with the
biggest and she's like but you you're
not going to want to have to hold a four
and a half pound breasts on you so lay
on your back will glue them and then you
can just hold them in place but you
don't have to hold them up because it
takes about a good you know whatever it
was like 15 plus minutes for the glue to
really dry in a fix right and then those
things aren't going to come off you it's
weird four and a half pounds is heavy
dude yes and pulling off of your skin
downward you could not rip it off if you
wanted to no it would rip my skin maybe
i don't i couldn't anyway i lay down i'm
i'm in her house it's 100 degrees it is
dark now it got dark out all of her
windows are open she goes back to
finishing dinner with a husband i don't
know them from a hole in a wall i'm
laying on her couch shirtless with two
double d fake black tits on me
i'm pouring sweat it's part nobody's
with you you're alive i'm completely
alone i'm pouring sweat it's puddling on
her couch i don't want to say anything
because i don't know them so they're
like quietly talking about their life
and they were like going through a tough
time with some tragedies and they were
like talking about serious issues and i
just hear like the fork and knife like
clinking against the plate it's like i
don't know if i'm gonna have enough
money and like do i like talking about
everything in english in english yeah
and then i remember i remember because
she kept using this term and she used it
for me too i was like what about this
and she goes don't worry she says if
worse she goes if worse comes to shove
that's what she said so she makes her
worse comes to worst and it pushes
himself so she kept on saying to me if
worth comes to shove yeah so i say that
to this day 20 years later so anyway i'm
laying on this 20 years ago it was uh we
did this pilot in
i'll tell you right now
we did the pilot in no it was in 2007.
okay so 14 years 14. wow so i'm laying
on the couch and i'm inside i'm looking
and then all of a sudden i hear like
what sounds like farting or like
wheezing yeah and it's like
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that and i
look down and on the floor is a cat and
the cat looks like it has moments to
live it looks like it's like it's 60
years old it's all matted it's wrapped
in uh gauze and it's leaking the cat is
leaking the gauze is wet and there's
like a puddle near it or something like
that and i was like oh my god i hadn't
noticed it before i didn't notice until
i was in silence and i heard like the
wheezing
i was like oh my god what's going on
she's like yes she's in a bad way we're
losing her these are probably her last
days or whatever and i was like oh my
god oh my god and i just lay there in
silence holding my black tits the 15
woman is listening to the cat leak and
die and listening to them talk about
literally die they're marital issues did
you have an urge just because now that
you know you have tits to just pick the
cat up and let it die slowly on your new
tits i didn't but i'm scared of cats
yeah but i will tell you though i was it
was very very weird like staring at the
ceiling in 100 degree apartment
listening to them talk about their bills
and listening to the cat die and i'm
bare chested
holding two humongous black breasts on
my body i had met her for the first time
in that moment
when you got up and they were finally
done did the husband just say bye to you
like i was very i didn't really talk
much to the husband i said take care
nice to meet you
and then you just put your shirt on with
your new huge tips i had to put the
shirt on try it try to different sizes
then she would put on a solvent peel it
off and i put on smaller tits
and
truthfully um i want to say like an hour
at least and then what size did you
leave with the biggest the biggest she
brought them to set
that can't be wrong see this here's the
thing that has to be saved with a pot of
this yeah i just want to say my balls
are gone i want to say
thank god this podcast is sponsored by
better help because the homeless pimp
just told us that
who wants to push a team
wrote to mcjohn mcdonald's in the famous
i need to go back to therapy now because
my balls and mine have been blown off
yeah
and better help can do it
are we doing a better help oh
i didn't know we did a better health
better helpful
i had no balls and head was blown off
because you just realized pusha t
made the bada
i'm loving it
that you could start communicating with
a licensed health professional which
i'll need to do in under 48 hours yes uh
yeah it's not a crisis line not out of
self-help we talk about this one all the
time because we love better help it's
professional counseling it's done
securely they have a broad range of
experts uh that you might not have
available to you locally uh the clients
uh you can be a client if worldwide
anyone can join that's right
you can log into your account anytime
and send the message to your counselor
and get timely results um do not send
your accounts in nude pics though
don't send pics
it's more affordable and traditional
than offline counseling and financial
aid is available but even if you do send
pics they don't throw you off they just
have a talk with you it happened to me
that's our key scroll a little bit pimp
betterhelp.com hey babe
that's a good promo code yes that's
better help and join over one million
people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using betterhelp.com
they're recruiting additional counselors
in all 50 states special offers and the
special offer hit him with it special
offer and yeah no in alaska they do it
live from an igloo yeah it's amazing
that's true um special offer for hey
babe listeners get 10 off your first
month at
betterhelp.com if you want 10 off you
know if you want to
save 10 percent get your mental health a
check just go to bedhealth.com hey babe
we got you covered babe
it's better help
i i will i can and will find a picture
for you of me bare chested with double d
black breasts do you remember if you
wrote that in your diary in one of your
diaries that we talked about on previous
episodes it had to have made the diary
what did you do today i put i i tried on
different sizes of black press it it had
to make it i have to pinpoint when that
was i'll go back and i'll look up summer
of 2016
journal entry you got to just remind i
got to do that summer 2007. yeah this
was right after that so it was right it
was 2000 2008 definitely the first one
that we didn't like we did in 2007 i
can't remember how close to it after
that the other one was but i'll look it
up and just see if i wrote that in how
funny is that like that you i mean
literally because i wonder if she
one of two things either
she didn't tell her husband that you
were coming over to do that that's why
he was like what the hell didn't care or
she literally does that weekly she she
she's a makeup profes yeah so i think
he's just used to it he didn't even
question no my mother's i didn't even we
didn't even speak like about like i
didn't speak with him about what was
going on what were they which was
another weird thing i don't know but it
wasn't all i remember though is like
with them talking and hearing like that
the fork and knife like like you know
how it like clings against the plate
like when people are eating because i
was just like laying there like please
god take me away follow it please make
me a bird take me away fall from here
we have to have to have to have to have
to get the picture of your boobs i rip
it open i i'll get you i should get us
the clip
where i rip it over how about get the
pilot yeah i i think we got it because
we were questioning whether we should
show clips of it in the new tour
i'm on sale now tenloins.com
i would i would say yes please show
clips of it on the new tour right yes
if i was sitting at home and said i've
seen the guys you know in whatever
respective city
maybe not this year i'll skip it but
then if i hear but sal is going to show
his fake black breasts video no i just
bought a ticket yeah you're right maybe
we should like bought a ticket maybe we
should do a bit where we like tell them
about this failed pilot that we made why
they just dissect the [ __ ] out of it you
should make it like the room that guy
took it on the road i know
speaking of big listen what i want you
guys to do is that we know you're
watching go to bring up bring your big
black titties to christy comedy.com as
well i got stan updates for if uh you
got how about this yeah baby i got shows
coming up in in in fort lauderdale
florida in los angeles california the
irvine improv zany's uh nashville i got
west palm beach florida and i got
phoenix arizona
why don't if you have
fake black boobs if you're a man and you
have fake black boobs on at the show i
will give you a free ticket
you go to christycomedy.com you got fake
black tits real i'm talking about
the ones that i got yeah not just glue
them you just stuff your you have to
glue them onto your chest if you do that
and you come and you show me the tits
you get a free ticket
i'll probably do that i'll i'll jump
i'll match you there we go i got some
dates coming up
i'll i'll do them separate my dates pimp
in case so you can add them when they
are actually there you go fake black
titties you'll get a freebie christy
comedy.com what if you go to your show
and is sold out in this 400 seats
throughout the venue holds and half of
them are male and like hundreds of men
have black breasts
do you do your material or is it just an
hour of
going over all the black breasts in the
in the crowd i would say in a situation
like that
knowing that i'm gonna now do an hour
and not make a dollar
i would just you know i think i would
just because they're all there free yeah
i would just i would just i would just
say you know what these people didn't
pay good money to see me they're getting
freebies they're getting a freebie what
if at five of these shows most people
come in fake black breasts affixed to
them and you just miss out on so much so
much money what are you gonna do
because they have the power now to write
this narrative for you yes the male's
listening now in those cities if you
just go on right now and order the
breasts to your home and a basic skin
glue
you can shave your chest calm for free
for free really create a story here
where
you basically usurp chris out of
tens and tens of thousands of dollars
and because you have to ask yourself for
you
is it i have a 45
or 40 general admission ticket maybe a
50 vip
do you want to forgo that
and spend hours and get fake black
breasts
just have to ask yourself if you want to
do that i want you to come to the show
i want you to come to the show outside
right now the fence
go to christy comedy.com that's all you
got to do how about this any women that
show black breasts free yes
yes
if you have black breasts of any kind if
you have even remotely just
above average
black bra even if you're a man you have
black brass gynocomastia tits i'll buy
you free i'll give you a free shot all
right how about that okay i'll do a shot
out of your belly button no i'm going
crazy again you're getting crazy yeah
you don't want to do that what can you
do that's like bathing with a scrub
daddy
hey if i survive bathing with a scrub
daddy i can do a couple of shots out of
people's belly buttons what do you have
rashes from the club what do you got i
just got an itch where
my lower back
a little bit under my taint i'm being
serious a little bit on my armpit well
you didn't come on now you didn't put
the scrub daddy's face in your taint
area not on my open pee hole but i
washed my genitalia with the scrub that
you did yeah
i was in the shower firm is it not firm
no when it gets wet it when it gets wet
which gets which is the big selling
point of the scrub it's only firm when
it's dry okay so when you were when you
were around your taint area wet yes
it literally the scrub daddy is the
exact same relationship i've been
recently having my girlfriend when it's
wet i'm soft when it's hard
she's dry
have you guys ever done body shots off
someone
i i have in my life off a guy or a girl
girl i mean like i remember like cancun
when i was like 20. you know
and then one time
one time i think
when i graduated from bartending school
maybe
no no no people were doing body shots i
didn't partake
yeah i'm trying to there was people who
did a body shot off somebody my teacher
ended up dating one of the students
and but he was awesome and she was
awesome
but they ended up dating when that's not
a teacher the class was over i was gonna
say but it's bartending school yeah it's
bartending so it wasn't like school then
we used to go and we would go out
because we made friends there and i
remember one time i have pictures of
them him doing body shots off of her can
you date if you're a college professor
of course the college students are above
age can you date like
that's a very good question that i don't
have you like legally a lot of people
what about graduate school like if i'm
35 years old second career graduate
school can i date my professor yeah what
if i'm a young professor
yeah i think it's a matter of not age
but at many schools there are no formal
rules about profession professors dating
students it is discouraged but not
prohibited for most educators there is
an unwritten rule that getting involved
with students is a bad idea it is
usually suggested that no professors
should date a student in his class um
we had a guy in our college that used to
be very forward
with people even during class not
forward he the way he spoke was
he used to come up he used to wear like
tight cotton dockers yeah and then we'd
be in our seats and he'd always walk
around like throwing chalk in the air
with his hands in his pockets
and uh he taught economics and saint
john's standing on campus and he used to
walk over to people and he was cool you
know he running a little bit of like a
boudin type right which i never watched
but last time i watched his documentary
if you want to talk about that yeah but
he would go over and he'd actually there
was an empty desk and he was talking to
you he'd go over and be like
he's going to go and then he'd ask
anybody so what do you think you know
like how do you like support he would
ask you the question that's on the board
but he'd just be like very confident and
he'd stand like this but we always were
like man he's really just throwing his
crotch right in everyone's face yeah you
know what i mean yeah
yes
you want to do you think do you think
that this is like i mean cuomo probably
you know
no i'm saying like that that's like
that's a you can't even his big thing
was that he was saying i guess i didn't
realize that the line was redrawn i read
that quote from him yeah yeah and and
because he was like i never knew i was
doing anything wrong and he also made a
quote cuomo he said i'm not a pervert
i'm just italian that's another thing he
said in his speech
no he didn't yes he did oh because
italians are like with like affection
and use their hands yeah which is wild i
mean that's good that should be merch
i'm not a pervert i'm just italian i
mean he could right now he trademarks
that throws it
i mean the irony of that's like just the
craziness the lunacy of that statement
well the cuomosexuals i mean you know
homosexuals was the whole movement in
the beginning of the pandemic like
sexual t-shirts and mugs and you know
mike racine great friend of the show you
know mike gracie of course he's been
tweeting out daily that have been dying
laughing about how he's like i have 1100
homosexual mugs somebody please take
them i have a family
i'm selling them he's like does he
really though no he's like the bit is
kidding yeah but he's like please i've
goddamn and i have all this homosexual
merch yeah we never knew how to take him
putting his leg up like that it was
always like is this hysterical or like
weird we don't know i had a teacher in
high school my english teacher nothing
sexual but used to sweat like
fully fully fully through his shirts i'm
talking about
pouring in sweat 12 months a year it
didn't matter just sweating sweating to
the point where one day and again there
was nobody had camera phones back then
so there are people at archbishop lloyd
high school can attest to this they were
in my class that did that that saw him
do this he just because all by catholic
high school said boys obviously you can
see i'm dripping here he said can i just
take the button down off and then he
swear to god undid his tie like didn't
undo it fully lucid took it off his neck
took off his button-down sweatshirt that
was literally soaking wet like he just
washed in the sink put it on the back of
his cherry i don't know undershirt wife
beat her put his tie back over his head
and was taught the rest of our english
class with the tie and the wife beat her
on i swear to god but you guys thought
it was hysterical we were
dying falling out of our seats he knew
it was funny he knew it was funny we
were seniors he knew it was funny but it
literally but he then but then it got to
the point where you know there was still
25 minutes left in the class so he you
know we were dying laughing but then he
just kept teaching at and then like we
got used to the fact that like if the
principal or any other teacher would
have walked in there and be like what
are you doing
but i never forget like he literally
did that and i was like that was awesome
but now you if you if he did that today
he would be put to death by a firing
squad
he would be killed in in eighth grade uh
our seventh grade teacher so in eight we
we were in catholics so we didn't switch
classes and teachers like public schools
do they switch classrooms and teach a
teacher switch which is a better idea
it it had different you think it's good
for the kids to get up and move to get
their blood flowing i i
moving and then having different
teachers maybe is probably better i
think than once you're saying have the
teachers move to you you don't move to
the teachers
we had one teacher for every subject ex
until we got together until we got to
eighth grade and then for social studies
we switched to one teacher for one
subject next door and it came right back
but it was exciting to like switch it
was cool to switch teachers but anyway
my point is that the teacher that was
our social studies teacher in seventh
and eighth grade that uh i won't say her
name on here but she was a young
attractive woman at that time i remember
she was 23. i'll remember this wow
all the boys in seventh eighth grade had
a huge crush on her right and i remember
one time even we had a sleepover
and we found not me but someone found
her name in the phone book and they
called her house and she had an
answering machine and they would call
and hang up just like oh my god look at
her it's her and then one time when my
friend's coat was called it was in the
middle of machine and my friend yelled
out
someone else's name
and then he yelled out his name and they
hung up so like she knows that they were
calling the house so she came into class
and i was like you guys you cannot call
my answer machine
and and do that so but she was really
pretty
and she had a a very attractive
shape
let's leave it at that got it and then
i'll never forget when we graduated
davey graduated in eighth grade my
friend frank walked out to her and gave
him her number
you can all you can't call past seven my
mom gets pissed
[Laughter]
she just i think she smirked he did it
in front of everybody are they are they
married to married today no yeah he went
to her and he gave him his number on a
piece of paper and he's like you know
yeah you know after i'm out of here if
you want to give me a call or whatever
that's dude that's so funny that's ball
she's 23 he was 13. 13. yeah
fast forward about i want to call it 50
let's call it 10 years now i'm like 23.
was i yeah now i'm like 23 ish i'm in a
bowling alley on staten island and i see
her so now she's 38.
right right no no sorry she's 33. she's
33. i'm 23. right yeah that christ died
33. isn't that so now isn't that a very
weird thing because 33 and 23
i don't see that that's not a big deal
you could absolutely if that guy had
given her a number 23.33
all is fine fine right fine yeah
so did she still have enough did she was
she still shapely she she looked older
she's still out of shape it was just a
different shape actually you know let me
let me actually say it might have been
longer i feel like she would have been
in her 40s so let's even go further you
were 33. yeah maybe it was like it was
because she was older looking when i saw
her now 33 and i remember saying to
myself
well
i wonder now if she is single and i
approached her right now and she we hit
it off i said i this is a wild thought
but i i maybe i could date my old
teacher and what happened did you give
it a shot no no i was in a relationship
and also i i wasn't going to do that but
like but if you were single you would
have given it i was like she felt it
felt like a world of difference like
this was an adult who was
like in our eyes gorgeous and like i was
never even it couldn't even be feasible
i was a child but when i saw her the
next time that's why it was the only
time i saw it since then it was like 15
years later i was like oh we're on equal
playing field you ready for this odd
ready for this what i'm about to tell
you
you know this is i swear to god 100 true
story okay i went out i love it i went
out on
multiple dates
multiple dates with my kindergarten
lunch monitor
no yes
my kindergarten
wow
because was she a student that was older
than you no it was like a high school
like job so she was like 16 or 18
whatever no no no no i'm sorry she must
no no no she was in her 20s when i was
five
and then when i was when i was 20
she was i guess in her mid to late 40s i
was a sophomore junior in college i went
on multiple dates with her
like literally
she was my lunch monitor you ran into
her somewhere well we she was always in
like the same you know the school the
same neighborhoods i always knew who she
was
i knew her kids she she lived in the
neighborhood of you yes we always kept
in touch
you kept in touch well no not kept in
touch you'd see her at church or in the
you know but she knew who you were when
you were in your 20s as identified as
the child from kindergarten or you later
figured out holy crap you were my
kindergartner no no no sheen always knew
no it wasn't like she knew like our
families were friends so she knew
that i was
and she always knew who i was how does a
date come about who is too how did this
happen who revealed that they had
i you ready for it how it happened
i accidentally i accidentally
needed i got i had her number
in my phone for something completely
benign like you know
i forgot what like i think it was maybe
something like when i was 17 or 18
she was running something that i wanted
to you know get extra credit for like
something like that like running the
cupcake thing at the school whatever
whatever and i actually because she
stayed as a ma as a worker yesterday she
was just a three year whole tenure as a
student yeah she was like a part of the
school board and all that stuff and i
was you know a part of that parish and
all that stuff so i accidentally
truthfully 1 000
accidentally
meant to text another girl
like a message like you're so hot or
something like that was sexual the girl
that i was talking to
that also began with that letter and i
accidentally texted that number because
i had gotten a new phone and so i sent
that to her she had my number saved
already from whatever the benign thing
and she goes she said something i forgot
what she said but whatever she said back
to me was enough to be like i said she
said something to me and i said i'm so
sorry obviously that was meant for
someone else and she said something
effective i was hoping it was meant for
me that would be fun
something like that god the laxticity of
something i swear to god dude 100 true
and you know what like [ __ ] it like with
the world that like we live in today
with like stuff like that that i guess
like
maybe is cool maybe isn't cool her name
was hey babe
[Music]
don't be um don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey